but first uh let's talk to our initial
guest who is uh sir ian diamond the head
of the office of national statistics a
very important week of course
uh to talk to him uh after those
questions asked about the way
uh that coronavirus statistics are
calculated thank you very much for being
with us uh this morning my pleasure
i just want to start uh with the uh
survey that you have been
uh carrying out recently trying to get a
bit of a
grip on the number of people who
currently have covered 19 and crucially
the number of people who have antibodies
to it as well what is it currently
showing
sure so what we've been doing is uh
testing in a sample of households right
across
england and testing everybody within
those households
and what we're showing is that across
england between 0.03 and 0.06
of a percent of the population have the
virus
at any time and to put that into uh
other numbers that's about one in every
two thousand um
three hundred people have got a virus
about seventeen hundred new cases
um a day and then we go further
and from a sample of that sample we we
take
blood samples so that we can look at
antibodies
in the population that's people who've
been exposed to
the virus and we find there
that around about 6.3 percent of the
population
have been exposed to the virus and
that's
around about three million people in the
population
so still obviously a very long long way
away from herd immunity
the government's been gradually easing
lockdown now
over a number of months have you started
to notice any uptick
in the number of people testing positive
for the virus
no we haven't we're basically flat uh
over the last few weeks uh
and clearly there are one or
two uh outbreaks in various parts of the
country and
over the next few weeks we will be
scaling up
our survey uh so that we have if you
like better
attraction on estimates right across the
country making
regional estimates in particular but
also uh being able then to have him
reserve
the opportunity to to to send extra uh
sample into areas where we start to see
the beginnings of an outbreak it's very
interesting to hear about the
focus on regional uh testing regional
uh sampling and do you think we need to
scale up testing across the united
kingdom really to get a bit more of a
grip about
where these outbreaks are then well i
think um
you know under the leadership of
baroness harding and there's been a big
move and certainly we have been helping
the joint biosecurity center to
to get really fast uh data not just
from testing but also for example from
measuring
uh the extent of the virus in wastewater
due to get early
early sites of any particular outbreak
and then you're absolutely right
there has to be very large uh testing
uh in those areas uh with tracing
to to be able to to keep the um
the epidemic under control uh and
certainly i think that's where that
uh if you like rise in the uh ability
of us to test and the number of tests is
incredibly important
yeah really important particularly of
course as the lockdown does continue to
be eased
um you were saying a little earlier that
things have been quite flat on the
number of infections
would you have expected uh to see
an increase in the number of infections
as lockdown was eased if it was going to
if you like lead to it i think it's a
really good
question sophie uh if i may and of
course
the answer really does depend on how the
population
works because you know the message has
been quite consistent and that if we
must
be alert and we must socially distance
and
if we are really super careful and if we
are able to
um follow all the rules it does seem to
me
that we should expect there to
be a relative um flatline
at the moment clearly um over the autumn
uh we will need to be ever vigilant
yeah certainly a really important thing
to go for
going forward i just want to talk to you
a little bit now about
the numbers and the data because it is
obviously
we're told by the government that the
government is using data to drive
the response to coronavirus to influence
policy and yet there's been a lot of
questions this week
about whether the data can be trusted
the health secretary
matt hancock uh are ordering this urgent
review into the way public health
england
counts coronavare's deaths in england
specifically uh saying that if someone
was previously diagnosed with covert 19
but subsequently died of unrelated
causes
they would still be classed as a
coronavirus death in that england
daily tally i mean this feels quite
astonishing to me
are these figures fit for purpose uh
well i think
i think it's really really important to
recognize that
different statistics are used for
different things
uh and so the phu data
are basically aimed to look at if you
like trends
over time in in in recent times if you
want to know
the accurate data on deaths then my
because i would say this but my
recommendation is that you go to the ons
data
why should you go to the ons data well
we believe very firmly
as does everyone that the very best
person
to take a decision uh around
what is the cause of death is the
medical practitioner who is there
at the time let's remember sadly um this
is
a loss every death or loss to to family
and to
to to friends and the medical
practitioner takes that view that's why
we are part of a who referral
group which very early in the pandemic
works out how to if you like make
covid19
a cause of death and then we worked with
our colleagues
at national records in scotland to to
get how to define that
into the advice that goes to medical
practitioners therefore
our data published weekly by
uh has by the medical practitioner a
decision on what
was the cause of death and i really
enjoyed your article by the way
that it was yesterday the day before but
i would say
that your point someone who had coveted
and then gets run over by a bus i think
it is
you know virtually it's inconceivable
but a medical practitioner
uh looking at a road accident he's going
to say that was the core the cause
was curving 19. therefore um my
recommendation
go with the ons data um we're a we
we've worked very hard to make our data
very quick
uh and probably um well it's certainly
among the fastest uh recorded uh
data by cause of death anywhere in the
world i mean
you're right of course the ons is the
gold standard of data and that different
statistics are used in different ways
but you can't really blame us for
focusing on the daily death data when
that was the one that the government was
talking about in its daily press
conferences
it feels to me like you're saying we
can't really trust it
i know that's true what i'm saying very
clearly is that we can trust
it to tell you whether there is a trend
in the last few days
or in the previous days that's exactly
what it was put together for
and that's exactly why it's there that's
why we we acknowledge you know for
example there are
always reductions in those later at the
weekend because
there are no registrations uh on that so
they so it allows us to look
at the recent trend but if you're
interested in the really accurate data
you you don't have to wait long let's be
honest stick with the ons data
okay uh the email on sunday reports
today that they think that the death
toll in england according to these phd
numbers could have been overestimated by
around four thousand people
do you think that's right well um
i need to to look very carefully um at
those data i mean i still stick very
much
with our data which uh are showing um
that around about forty eight thousand
one hundred fifty four people at the
moment have
been reported as dying due to covet and
those are the data that i would stick
with
okay now it's not just the phe data that
there's been a question mark over
it too sky news investigation found that
at the height of the pandemic
the government overstated the number of
people who had been tested for
coronavirus
by 200 000. we were told two million
people have been tested by mid-may
that was then revised down to 1.8
million i mean the statistics we have on
coronavirus
are dictating the policy the data is so
important when it comes to public
confidence how have we gotten such a
mess over numbers
well because it's great to have data
journalists such as ed conway working
with you
uh sophie as i may say so and look
you know i think early on in those
testing statistics
we were putting something together new
uh as a country
and i think there were some challenges
and i have to say when s has worked
hard with dhsc to
get into a position where we can trust
those data and the letter last week from
the office of statistics regulation
that's the statistics regulator
um complementing um the progress that
had been made
i think is an important moment okay now
the uk was also quite slow to
recommend the uh use of face masks face
coverings uh to stop the transmission of
the virus i know you've been doing a bit
of work
on whether or not people are wearing
them now uh what what
is it that you've been finding sure um
well
we have also had a weekly survey which
has gone out to a
some a representative sample of the
population right across the country
uh and we analyze those data incredibly
quickly and what we're showing
is that we come week there is an
increase in the number of people who are
using face covering so last week the
data published
uh just four or five days ago uh would
show that 61 of the population
had used um face covering in the last
week
and that's up from 50 uh the week before
um in in scotland 77 percent of the
population using
it for shopping and that that i think
will continue to go up as it's become
mandatory um in england 40 but of course
as that becomes mandatory next saturday
uh we will see that increase as well
but certainly uh people using uh face
covering and becoming it becoming
the norm in many uh parts of society
very interesting to see uh that kind of
significant change uh in such a quick
period of time and just finally i just
want to talk about the economic hit
of coronavares because there was hope
that we would
bounce back quite quickly once lockdown
was over but i have to say if you look
at the latest gdp data
it shows the economy only grew 1.8
in may now that of course is much lower
than the 5.5 percent expected
is the idea of a v-shaped recovery for
the birds
certainly not um but equally
it's too early to tell certainly that
one point eight percent
which is 24.5 percent lower than
february
was uh lower than uh many analysts
were expecting and hoping for uh and
um we will be looking over the next
little while
to see the extent to which um
it increases certainly we did see some
some indication with manufacturing up
eight percent of construction up eight
percent
of a return but clearly there is much to
do
in places like hospitality uh and
in accommodation i would say again that
our data
are showing that week on week people
are more saying they are more likely
to to go to a restaurant for example
and so we will i think see the economy
pick up but how fast it will pick up
with that v-shaped recovery that you
referred to sophie
it's too early to tell really
interesting to talk uh city and diamond
thank you very much for being on the
program this morning thank you
it's been my pleasure thank you